[Music]
so in in this environment
roy give me your top defy or crypto
investment is there an altcoin that you
think has room to rally give me in in
two sentences your top investment in the
space right now i'm going to disappoint
you right now because i don't have a
pick
past the upper tier which of course is
bitcoin and ether and the reason i don't
have a pick there is that when it
becomes when these coins become
accessible let's call them the the the
d5 top 10 which is
you know this 10 to 30 billion dollar
uh side chains
etc
these coins are available to the public
and you're going to hear about them long
after the venture capital firms that
funded these have bought and pre-mined
everything at 1 100 the cost you're
going to pay if you're buying solana
right now you're going to pay 100 or so
what it originally was
15 cents so we've had massive price
appreciation already and i don't see
these as unique and different enough
from each other that it's easy to pick a
winner it's it becomes like picking
stops so then let's go to the problem
all right so then let's go to the
ethereum 2.0 point that i touched on
with kevin and he makes a valid point
that this has been anticipated for a
very long time and yeah it could also go
very wrong what is your view on how this
ethereum 2.0 merger works out so i think
it's going to happen and i think it's
going to happen because ethereum despite
being supposedly decentralized is
actually a lot more centralized than it
seems and i think the people at its core
want this to happen and this by the way
is a reason why proof of work is very
valuable compared to proof of stake so
remember proof of work is what bitcoin
has that's all the energy utilization
anyone can go out there and buy miners
and buy energy and mine bitcoin and
participate in the governance of bitcoin
however that's not true if in ether
ethereum blockchain favors the largest
holders and so it's not as decentralized
so i am not as bullish on the idea of
proof of stake as a replacement for
proof of work it's an alternative it has
some advantages and has some
disadvantages and to me i'd rather i
think it's a good thing that we're using
one 500th of all human carbon emissions
with the potential to get billions of
people decentralize finance okay but you
have also invested uh quite
significantly in other protocols and
projects
i'm sure that you're saying that that no
one that neither are going to trump
bitcoin or ethereum but which of these
projects do you think will gain i think
adoption portfolio just like in in
stocks a proper portfolio should use the
wisdom of the market i always tell
people if you want to invest in the
stock stock market buy the s p 500 and
yeah you get a lot of apple and you get
a lot of tesla in there but those are
really really good companies amazon is
in there and huge in the index for a
reason and the same thing if you're
going to buy cryptocurrencies for a
long-term hold
then you want a lot of bitcoin and a lot
of ethereum and a lot and much smaller
amounts of everything else
so to i think the number is about uh so
you don't have a third pick for for uh i
do not have a third pick i think it's
fine to trade these things and have fun
with them but i don't see the potential
in the others in any one particular coin
all right kevin what are you identifying
as the biggest opportunity in in crypto
and d5 at the moment then
well i own all of the uh you know
positions that
that we're always talking about on an
index basis and i indexed up to five
percent weighting maximum across 20
percent old which is a standard uh
indexing
practice for sovereign wealth funds
that's just
you know milk bone strategy but i've
gone a little farther i've decided that
i'd like to own some of the
infrastructure of web203o and so i've
taken equity positions where regulators
allow it and that's primarily canada the
neo exchange is the preferred exchange
now it's it's been announced the cboe is
buying it uh so it's going to be a
basically an american exchange but
housed in canada but it has companies
like wonder fi on it and now that that
means bit buys on it too that was the
first license granted by the regulator
there it trades as an equity
wndr and also immutable holdings a
company that's headquartered basically
in puerto rico
where they are building out this huge
platform for nfts they own nft.com
they're a blockchain company you can buy
those equities on the neo exchange in
canada where the regulator allows it and
so some of these companies get listed in
in norway and germany where regulators
allow it but for me those are also uh
full weightings i've got five percent
waitings in those names because i want
to own the picks and shovels it's not
just the gold that people made money on
the gold rush it was the picks and
shovels so in my portfolio i've got a
lot of picks and shovels and again it's
all software you meet these executives
in these companies they're young really
strong engineers in there and they don't
want to work for industrial companies
anymore they want to be on the chain
that's where the future is and they're
the smartest hands and that's where they
make the most money because they're
cutting edge advances in financial
services so that's the investment thesis
it's not just bitcoin you know some of
these equities have actually
outperformed
bitcoin for me because they've had
dramatic moves as markets start to
recognize the merits of owning these
companies yeah but again it's like roy
said i bought these in you know
fractional prices on their on their
first and second rounds and now they're
trading and they've moved
materially so i'm going to keep doing
the same thing that same thing with the
norway project that's private
what about investors that
do not have the opportunity like you did
to invest in one defy and immutable
holdings which as you said have now
listed point they can now if they wish
they can now
there are there are other picks that you
are viewing as having tremendous growth
potential as well in the as you so call
it uh infrastructure side of things yeah
yeah i would say the other opportunity
it's a short marathon short hive short
hud eight and short um riot those stocks
are going to get killed when they get
their carbon
carbon audits started on them because
there's there's nowhere to go there's
just no way to audit it they're not
going to get an auditor to sign those
statements
it's unfair in some ways i mean
basically this is a classic case where
the nation industry started just a few
years ago by these great pioneer
entrepreneurs they get shot with all the
arrows because the president loves
climate change mandates and so does so
does black rock and so does the sec now
and and so does the the luminous bill so
i mean that's unfortunate but sometimes
you know the pioneers have to get the
arrows so that the ones that come behind
them can set up shop all right uh kevin
you meant i know you're big into nfts as
well you've said that in five years time
the market cap of all nfts will exceed
bitcoin
i'd like for you to explain how you see
that happening
and more importantly
if an investor wants to capitalize on
this nft
craze what's the best way to do it
you know i don't buy uh jpeg nfts i'm
not in the lazy ape thing or crazy
what i do is i look for use cases that
create economic value and the one i've
been talking about a lot lately i'm not
the there's lots of other ones but the
one that's so obvious and easy to
understand because people like watches
is the watch industry so the watch
industry about 12x
there's billions of dollars a quarter
trading in secondary markets for watches
the rolexes patek philippe adam rpk fb
journal all these watches the majority
of them are fake
that's what's happened you know you see
a
you see a daytona like this go from
thirteen thousand to sixty thousand
dollars there's a lot of motivation for
people to rip them off
that wouldn't happen if there had been
an nft minted
at the actual factory the micro scan the
dial at a high resolution because every
dial has micro imperfections in it and
then created an nft that traveled with
the ownership in other words give me the
ownership papers digitally there's a
tremendous economic value in that and
that's an nft market that's going to
explode to the upside as once once the
white paper is released from the
horological society that's where we're
going same with real estate same with
antique cars same with pens same with
jewelry same with all the collectibles
that have physical value and asset that
will be turned into digital ownership
and then can be moved from wallet to
wallet as the watch gets traded and the
royalties can go back in the smart
contract to the rolexes and the patex
and the fp journals because they
provided and minted the nft in the first
place
that makes sense to me the rest of the
stuff very speculative do i need do i
want to pay 360 000 for a lazy ape
no
i believe it's crazy but i'm not
entirely sure about that one
bored crazy and lazy that's a good
combination not really uh roy very
quickly from an institutional side and
very quickly because i do want to bring
in our audience questions now what's
your view on
funds being exposed to the nft sector
what way would they go about doing that
is that something you're looking at i'm
not at all interested in
well for me any piece of art has to have
craft beauty
and some sort of transporting quality
that
enhances your experience
nothing i've seen in the in the digital
space does that
essentially there's an unlimited supply
of every adjective followed by aid
followed by or any other animal type and
that's so i have not no interest
whatsoever
maybe you can make a case for the first
set of popular nfts and crypto kitties
maybe are it's like cave paintings in a
sense you might make a case for that as
the first nfts but
regulators gonna come down on this stuff
what are they gonna exactly yeah these
are security there's no question so
anyway my my view is exactly the same as
kevin's that there are real use cases
for these real estate any hard asset can
be uh it can be put on a blockchain and
you can do provenance you can do
fractional ownership the sec eventually
is going to have to give us the
regulatory framework and plenty of money
will be made however
i don't necessarily think that people
are going to pay a lot of money for this
uh process to happen you know if you
think about it putting some things on
the blockchain is not that difficult so
i'm not sure that there's a hundred
billion dollar nft company but there's
certainly
a trillion dollars of potential nft
value that will exist on a blockchain
okay you both mentioned regulation i
just want to wrap up this portion before
we bring in our audience questions uh
kevin with regulation and you touched on
the executive order from the biden
administration that was released on
digital assets and it stated that around
16 of adult americans approximately 40
million people have invested in traded
or used cryptocurrencies
now kevin we've had guests on the show
saying
that because of that a bitcoin ban is
now impossible that it is political
suicide to alienate that proportion of
voters
can we lay the bitcoin ban concept to
rest can we safely say that the us
outright banning bitcoin and other
cryptos is no longer an existential
threat
yes we can there's no chance that we're
going to be banning bitcoin or anything
else that
holds economic promise in terms of
developing new technologies for
financial services and payment systems
that's always been the hallmark of
american entrepreneurship we're not
going to ban that most of the engineers
today that are working on these projects
see tremendous potential transparency
audits everything they provide so much
uh upside that they'll they'll
they'll remain going but the one thing
that's 100 sure is they're going to be
regulated 100
but i'd argue that's good news we get
this regulation in place the
institutional institutions will pour in
trillions of dollars those that have
been speculators like roy and i will
benefit from the fact that these will
get indexed and that will be a great
upside and then the then what happens
after that is based on market demand
based on indexing the majority of the
ownership will shift the institution the
majority of of the s p is on my
institutions people think retail owned
stocks no they don't you know it's like
facebook the reason it got crushed was
that it got re-indexed from five percent
down to two and a half and it took four
weeks to flush all that out because of
the new perceived risk and the metaverse
and everything else that is not a retail
stock that is an institutional stock it
was one of the fangs still is but it's
all institution and that's the that's
the upside and the potential of bitcoin
so roy do you think there's going to be
do you think there's going to be like a
moment of definitive clarity
where it's made official that some ban
is not going to happen and if so what do
you think that does to the price no i i
think there's always a chance for a ban
i absolutely think there's a chance that
bitcoin could be banned look they
private ownership of gold was banned in
many many countries including the united
states so could it happen absolutely
however
were that to happen
it would be such an environment of chaos
and hyperinflation that bitcoin would be
worth even more money at that point if
they're gonna ban it it's going to be
the time when you absolutely want to
load up on bitcoin because it will only
be in such a chaotic situation that the
only thing you can transact it is
bitcoin
all right um kevin we have a question
from someone in our audience for you
uh he riley bayton i believe is asking
when do you think a u.s bitcoin spot etf
is going to be approved do you think
we'll see that by 2022 that's a question
from riley bington
no not in 2022
not until the bill is voted on that the
senator loomis is putting forward so
that's going to be probably after the
midterms
2023 2024 and it'll also include a
mandate for other etfs they'll just copy
the canadian order which has worked so
well there was such a concern to be
massive tracking error there isn't it
trades in uniform with the underlying
bitcoin ethereum so the same idea can be
put onto the nyser or the nasdaq that's
coming and but it simply won't happen
until some of these mandates and these
regulations have been put in place and
become law
okay uh we have another question for you
kevin from genie in a bottle it's about
the crypto winter there's concern that
we're deep in equip to winter which as
we know is defined as a prolonged period
of stalling price action after a big
price rally uh we know that that's
happened several times since bitcoin's
inception in 2010 and the last time we
had such a winter was in 2018 to early
2020 after the price on bitcoin crashed
about 70 percent from its december 27
highs jeannie in a bottle kevin would
like to know whether you think we're in
a crypto winter now
and when do you expect
spring to start what would trigger a
crypto spring
so the reason we're not going to be in a
crypto winter again is that the last
crypto winter had no possibility
of policy
or regulation that is not the case today
there's enough believers that this
regulation will be a good thing watching
these bills go through it's very rare to
see a bipartisan bill in today's
congress but you have one here which
means both sides understand the merits
of cryptocurrencies
and so you have a ted cruz uh you know
sitting right beside a democrat which
never happens
and so i look at it and say to myself
that's one of the reasons there's a bid
an underlying bid on bitcoin and other
uh cryptocurrencies because there's an
assumption in the next two years
something will happen that did not exist
in the last
winter
all right roy um we have a question for
you um it is from virtual console
and they'd like to ask you your thoughts
on the future of polygon roy
what what's your thesis on polygon where
do you see that going
i i own a lot of medic i think it's a
very good coin very good token um so
it's not that i don't have these things
it's a very easy blockchain to use it's
inexpensive
i would say the developer network is not
as strong as what we're seeing in some
of the other ones like solana like avax
but i think it's a fine thing to have
some of again i don't necessarily see
the appreciation potential that i see
for the largest uh
for the for the largest things in the
space and i i think in in general i want
to make a a to reiterate a point that we
touched on before
right now there is an incredibly
motivated minority 16
of americans who hold cryptocurrency who
will be furious if anything goes wrong
in their industry and
there's no one who is i think
pounding the pavement and rioting
because they want to ban
cryptocurrencies and when you have that
situation i think we're going to see
very benign legislation and benign
regulation i think you could even feel
it in the announcement of biden's
announcement where he said basically
we're going to have a committee to
develop recommendations that's what
organizations do when they want to slow
play and basically don't do nothing
and so i feel like we are in that was an
extraordinarily positive development you
could easily have seen fiery language
like this is the world of money
launderers and wasteful carbon emissions
and we have to take action against this
danger
so
um
roy we have a question for you uh from
cassius cuvee he's a big fan of kitko uh
he says i'm asking basically about the
flow of overall money if you think it
will disproportionately flow back into
crypto more than what came out
more than gold was it more than what
money came out of crypto oh
yes i think we're going to see far more
acceptance as in institutions trillions
and trillions of dollars
of total assets of which
some percent will be placed in
the largest cryptocurrencies because of
the chance that my thesis might be
correct i just want to reiterate that my
i'm not suggesting that this is a likely
outcome that we're going to have 10
inflation
forever we're going to have 15
but it's certainly a pretty good
possibility and
it's a lot more of a possibility when
we've actually had inflation of about 15
or 20 percent
and what i mean by that is if you
calculate inflation
the way they used to do it in 1990 our
inflation rate is already over 15 so
we're already there at my middle case
uh okay kevin a question for you from
patent expert he'd like to know how does
hbar and hedera play into the crypto
market software scenario
again you're trying to guess the use
case and if you believe there's economic
value
um
you you may allocate and so these are
not my largest positions by any means
but
in the case of hbar the easy way to
understand it is it's a it's a
quasi-decentralized quasi-centralized
chain and the reason you it needs to be
that way is when you're a boeing or a
large global manufacturer you want some
element of centralization because you're
trying to control
supply chains which has become a big
buzzword in the last two years because
of the pandemic and indeed has slowed
down some manufacturing including the
aerospace industry so hbar's being used
as a as a use case for actually making
it easier to track and control and make
the supply chain more productive now if
you believe and as i do that's going to
work to some level well there's a lot of
economic value there in other words if
it works for boeing it'll work for
others in that space they'll standardize
on that industry on that particular
chain that's what happens with these
chains once a a player in an industry
says well this is great for me like
solana they're trying to make the number
one at you know chain for nfts and that
may happen because it's very fast way
faster than what's going on in ethereum
before it goes to proof of stake and who
knows if it really will speed up if that
happens if it happens and so a lot of
this development work going on is being
funded by the foundations and i know in
the case of
ftx where you know i'm a shareholder and
i'll disclose again a paid spokesperson
they have billions of dollars to put to
work to develop these chains for their
benefit and the benefit of all everybody
on their platform and so these are
behemoth platforms
you think about it's kind of interesting
because ftx is a centralized platform
that's investing in decentralized
wallets why are they doing that because
it's smart to do that acquire the
customer once never lose them provide
them with decentralization for maybe
nfts or whatever else they want but keep
a centralized wallet for large holdings
that have to be audited and they need
the infrastructure for compliance so i
think all of this is to come but i'll
just tag it again by saying it's all
just software
all just software
uh kevin we have a question for you
although you've already touched on it
but we'll let you reiterate that point
because the challenge is one of the
things you said about carbon credits and
mining companies it's from zak g
and he'd like to know your thoughts on
investing in crypto mining companies
that use renewable energy you've already
given us those versus fossil fuel
powered miners saying that hive
blockchain uses a hundred percent
renewable energy to power their
operations
i know you said that hive blockchain is
gonna be in for a main audit
you can well i'm not investing in any
blockchain mining company that answers
the question
about carbon credits with yes we use
them so in other words the way to avoid
disaster in my view as a personal
opinion is ask the company you claim
your carbon neutral but are you using
carbon credits to get there and the
answer is yes
avoid like the plague because that's
going to have a horrible outcome in just
a very short period of time
the only companies that can claim that
they're really clean
are hydro and nuke and there's more
hydro opportunity right now than nuke so
if the only ones i'm investing in can
show me with hunt 100 percent
auditability that they're getting all of
their power from hydropower
all right um thanks for that kevin roy
we have a question for you from onion
farmer and he'd like to know what is the
best way to create yield using your
bitcoin and other alt coins if there are
any platforms that you prefer
that's a very very good question and i
haven't mentioned this but one of the
things that makes cryptocurrency so
interesting is actually their yield play
right now
your your baseline yield in
places like celsius
is about three or four percent on
investments in if you just give them
your bitcoin to custody
like a bank but they'll pay a lot more
than a bank does
there are other ways to get a lot more
yield and
many of them involve providing liquidity
in liquidity pools and also taking
advantage of what i would call the
defy
subsidy which is related to the
millennial lifestyle subsidy that
brought us uber and doordash and all
these companies that are providing
services below cost
right now there's a tremendous race to
see who's going to be the amazon
of defy who's going to be the one
financial services company
that provides those billions of people
financial services and vcs are throwing
money at projects to see if they can get
the one that really succeeds and in
order to do that to get those
projects going and scale
they're subsidizing the investments in
these projects with enormous amounts of
money and you can capture that so there
are two different types of trades that
are pretty interesting right now one is
to provide money into market makers
essentially uh people that want to be
decentralized exchanges and another one
is uh incentivized leveraged lending
platforms where you basically get paid
to invest in the platform and then get
paid to borrow against the capital that
you've just invested in the platform
rinse and repeat and you can get some
pretty interesting yields and there you
can go way above
five ten percent into the twenty thirty
forty percent and depending on how they
call it d gen you wanna be you can get
even higher than that with of course can
measure at risk
all right uh kevin to roy's point
and as someone that invests in these uh
companies that are trying to provide
these d5 solutions what do you think
could be the amazon of the space
i think it's too early to tell which is
why there's so many different bets being
put out there it really is
the outcome of different geographies i
mean you think about the behemoth ftx
has become they did it all outside the
united states
they didn't come here because the
regulatory environment didn't provide
for what they needed for their clients
and so
it's not clear to me who's going to be
the winner in the long run
it really will depend when and if the
u.s regulator
defines global policy which i think the
sec will do it's done in every other
market you look at the policies in
european markets or asian markets around
equities
they mirror very close to what the sec
has mandated and so i think we're going
to get the same thing happening in
crypto it's going to take a little
longer in the meantime there'll be lots
of volatility lots of opportunity but
it's a little different than stocks and
bonds
you need you need executional skills as
a software engineer to pull this off you
you can't just say well here's my vision
for my blockchain you gotta actually
deliver it you gotta test it you gotta
prove it has scalability and you've got
to prove it has scale in terms of number
of transactions per second all of this
stuff is not easy to do which is why i
take a multi-bet approach you know maybe
it'll be solana maybe it won't be maybe
it'll be polygon maybe it won't be maybe
it's avalanche i don't know maybe it's
helium i don't know i have some of that
too so you know it's it's all about
outcomes you just don't know
and kevin what are your thoughts on
platforms like celsius for example that
allow you to get yield on your coins
yeah i mean
roy gave a good use case of how yield
works
i prefer to stay a little bit more
conservative i'm using circle i have a
corporate account there i'm writing
30
60 12 month contracts
yields are about 4.2 percent today
and my auditor
and my compliance department are willing
to allow me to hold up to a five percent
waiting in any one mandate even though i
must tell you it took me six months to
get them on board even for a stable coin
the problem is there are stable coins
being litigated by the sec right now not
usdc
but while that litigation is unresolved
it puts a taint on the entire entire
stablecoin
industry and so really you should view
stablecoins as no different than a
fidelity money market but they are not
the same because the regulator says
they're not the same so what is the
underlying if it's not a us dollar well
i have to tell you something money
markets have lots of non-us dollar
assets in them but they've been
regulated for decades so there's a lot
more comfort there
all right we're gonna wrap it up with a
final thought from both of you regarding
central bank digital currency speaking
of stable coins and such because and
i'll start with you kevin you've said in
the past during our interviews that
a fed coin a central bank digital coin
from the us government is not going to
happen that you think there are very
very low odds of fed coin happening
and that governments will likely just
adopt or modify an existing stable coin
is that still your position there
yeah it is you don't see government
mutual funds or money market funds
because they let the industry innovate
and the same thing is going to happen
here they'll license between five and
ten stable coins and let them compete
with with features because again it's
software and how well the platform works
i mean if you looked at
circle as a software platform eight
months ago and looked at it today it's
completely different they've advanced so
many different features because they've
had to i mean even i've had feedback to
them saying look my auditor wants this
my auditor wants that my compliance
department wants this add this treasury
tab all this stuff so i mean they're
doing all that i i would be very
encouraged by one index that i don't
think enough people have considered
bitcoin 2022
is is you know came out of nowhere and
has become
the de facto global gathering
of bitcoin the granddaddy digital asset
this year it's going to run for three
days it's taking over the entire
convention center in miami where i live
that's a big facility but what's
remarkable
the first day the sixth
it's all institutions and it's totally
sold out that has never happened before
that'll be 1500 to 2 000 institutions
from all around the world there
to hit to listen to different thoughts
about where we're going with this thing
i'll be doing a keynote exactly on this
esg issue because it's top of the line
for everybody i'm going to lay out the
data i've got and you know we'll have
that discussion but it's institutions
only
that is remarkable
all right well kevin we will see you in
miami again looking forward to it uh roy
i do want to get your thoughts though
before we wrap on the likelihood
of fedcoin a central bank digital
currency coming out of the u.s
i think in general governments love to
exert power and control over their
citizens i think we're going to see the
fed try to have full transparency over a
stable coin maybe it will be one they
develop maybe they'll license one
but what we see in china right now with
social credit can you imagine a u.s
government that has the power to look at
every single financial transaction you
make prohibits some of them
and yeah extract taxes
automatically they can have negative
interest rates very very easily by just
taking your stable coins away this is a
extraordinarily nefarious development
and it doesn't solve anything because of
course a fed coin can be printed just
like the us dollar because that's all it
is it's just a us dollar and you have in
digital form and it has the same supply
problems that has caused me to be so
bullish on bitcoin and ethereum yeah um
i personally find the idea of fat coin
terrifying for many of the reasons you
listed and more um yeah i certainly
don't want to be a canadian or u.s
trucker with a fed coin in my uh wallet
but that of course just bolsters the
case for bitcoin i think we we all agree
on that
all right well you know i just want to
say something about that roy as a
canadian citizen i'm also irish i'm also
emirati i'd like to apologize on behalf
of all canadians we will be getting rid
of trudeau very shortly don't worry
we're going to vote we're going to vote
him out of power that was an absolutely
abysmal performance and he has been
rebuked recently in the general council
in europe they're very pissed at him and
so am i well kevin i know we have had
the pleasure of discussing your
political aspirations in the past so uh
i'm just going to say is that something
we can look forward to in the future
no i'm going to support john charae i
think he'll be prime minister of canada
he's a centralist he's a moderate and he
supports bitcoin and policy that has
already been developed and even more
he's going to be i believe
the crypto prime minister because he
knows that's on mandate for so many
young canadians are going to vote for
him on that platform alone and we will
finally get rid of
we need adult supervision in canada we
need to get rid of trudeau he's just a
miserable manager very successful
politician in longevity but the worst
manager i have ever seen ever
if you like that video wait did you see
my next one don't forget to click right
over here and subscribe